The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: Now, also, before
I begin today's lecture,
I want to comment a bit about
what's going on in the news,
because last time, on
Monday, we said-- or I said--
that the Fed was
going to cut rates.
[LAUGHTER]
And in fact, if you looked
at the data on Monday
and you looked at things
like the Fed fund's future
and other financial
contracts, the market
had priced in the
fact that the Fed
was going to cut at
least 25 basis points,
and actually a reasonable
probability that it
was going to cut 50.
And of course, they did neither.
They actually held rates steady.
But they did do something.
What did they do?
Anybody know?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Extended [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: How large a loan?
$85 billion, which, even among
friends, is a lot of money.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, this is yet again an
extraordinary and unprecedented
measure.
We know that the Fed did
backstop Bear Stearns.
But the Fed didn't spend any
direct money on Bear Stearns.
They basically got JP
Morgan to buy Bear Stearns
and negotiated the deal.
In this instance, the Fed
is lending money to AIG,
lending $85 billion.
And AIG isn't even a bank.
So what do you
think is going on?
Does that make sense?
What does that tell you about
what's going on in markets?
The fact that everybody thought
the Fed was gonna cut rates,
and they didn't--
that shows a certain
kind of restraint.
In fact, I think it
was in this class
that somebody mentioned, well,
rates are already down at 2%.
How much more can they cut?
I mean, if they cut
50 basis points,
that leaves them very
little flexibility.
And also, if you think that the
reason we are in this crisis
is because borrowing has been
so low for so long, that people
have been going out making
all these bad loans when they
shouldn't be doing
that to begin with,
cutting rates is not going
to really help that situation
but can only encourage it.
Nevertheless,
there was a crisis.
Certainly over the weekend,
we had some very bad news.
Lehman Brothers went under,
and the Fed did what?
Nothing.
So if the Fed did
nothing for Lehman,
yet they extended an $85
billion loan for AIG,
something's got to be different.
Right?
I mean, I guess you
could see whether or not
Ben Bernanke has a
brother-in-law working at AIG,
but I don't think that's it.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [? But today it was ?]
reported that Barclays is
actually going to go ahead
and buy [? them. ?] So what
changed--
ANDREW LO: Well,
the announcement
is that Barclays is buying some
of the US operations of Lehman
Brothers.
They are cherry-picking the
operations that they want.
What Lehman tried to do over
the weekend was broker a deal
where Barclays would
buy all of them,
assume all their
obligations, and allow
them to keep on going as
a going business concern.
Barclays couldn't do that,
because they couldn't
get shareholder
approval quickly enough,
and also ostensibly
because the Fed would not
backstop any losses that
Lehman had hidden in its books.
And in a matter
of 48 hours, it's,
kind of, hard to figure
out all the buried bodies
in an organization as complex
and as large as Lehman.
But Barclays is going ahead
and purchasing those units
that they like, and
there are many units
at Lehman Brothers that are
extraordinarily profitable,
very good businesses
with excellent people.
So Barclays is going
ahead with those.
And by the way, there are
all sorts of other sharks
that are swimming around
Lehman, cherry-picking various
different groups.
This is part of the problem
with these this kind
of financial distress.
We're going to actually get
to this at about lecture 18.
We're going to talk
about financial distress,
and I'm going to bring you
back to Lehman Brothers
and ask you to think
about the problems
that this company faces.
Because think about it.
Now that it's been announced
that Lehman is liquidating--
well, let me put it this way.
Suppose you were working
at Lehman Brothers,
suppose that you've
been there 15 years,
and suppose that
you were running
one of the most successful
proprietary trading groups
at Lehman Brothers.
And now, this news comes up,
and it's a surprise to you.
What is your first reaction?
What are you going to do?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Right.
That's certainly one thing.
You're going to take a look
at what your positions are.
And then, after you
establish that you're
OK in terms of your
trading positions,
what's the next thing
you're going to do?
What are you gonna
start thinking about?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Start
bringing your resume?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
You're going to
start looking around.
So you're going to talk to lots
of other people about, maybe,
moving your entire
group of 15 people
that you've hand-picked
and developed
over the last 15 years.
And you're gonna start
talking all sorts
of other counter-parties
to move your entire group.
And now, Barclays decides to
buy Lehman, the operations
that you're a part of.
But there's no slavery
in the United States,
at least not since
the 1800s, which
means that if you
want to walk, you can.
So if Lehman buys--
if Barclays buys Lehman and
buys the group that you're in,
and you're one of the most
profitable parts of that,
you don't have to stay.
So in addition to
paying for Lehman,
Barclays is also gonna
have to talk to you
and get you to stay,
which means that they're
going to have to pay you
an extra bonus and all
of your people bonuses to stay.
So now, the price of
having to keep Lehman
together has just
gone up dramatically,
because you've got to
keep all of the talent,
and it's very hard to do that.
So the fact that
Lehman is in trouble
has caused all sorts
of problems and will
create additional amounts
of frictions and payments
that otherwise wouldn't
have had to be.
So I want you to keep that
in the back of your minds--
the costs of financial distress.
We're going to come back to
that in, about, 10 lectures.
OK so-- yeah, question?
STUDENT: I heard a [? quote ?]
with regards to the Fed action,
that the Fed decided
that the problem is not
the cost of money but
the supply of money.
So they're going to infuse
capital into the market.
Is that just referring
to the AIG 85 billion,
or is there some other way
that they're infusing capital?
ANDREW LO: No.
Well, that's certainly one way.
But the other way is that they
are allowing the other banks
to borrow from them
at a lower rate.
So the discount window
that typically banks
go to borrow from the Fed--
they're making more money
available in that way.
And other central banks
are doing the same thing--
injecting money into
the system in order
to calm the fears
of individuals.
STUDENT: Does that lower the
effect of [? interest rate? ?]
ANDREW LO: Well, we're going
to see that in a minute.
We're going to actually--
one of the things
I want to talk about today
is, exactly what do we
see from market prices?
Now, on Monday, I claimed that
market prices was telling us,
there's going to be a Fed cut.
Clearly, it was wrong.
Now, that's a very good
lesson, because what
this is telling us is that
market prices have information,
but as I told you last time,
they're not a crystal ball.
They're not perfect, and
so they can be wrong.
Apparently-- and this
is now very speculative.
Apparently, the Fed
decided, as you pointed out,
that it's not the availability
of-- or rather the cost
of funds.
That's not what's important,
but rather the availability.
In other words, they're
worried about a credit
crisis, a crisis of liquidity.
And AIG is a very important
player in that respect--
apparently, much
more so than Lehman.
Because Fed didn't do
anything to try to keep Lehman
from going under,
but an $85 billion
loan was what they decided
was appropriate for AIG.
The reason for that--
the ostensible reason.
Who knows what the
real reasons may be?
But the reasons that
we think this happened
is that AIG provides
enormous amounts of insurance
to a variety of other players
in the credit markets.
And if they go
under, if they decide
that they can't make good
on those insurance claims,
what happens is that
those investors that
are holding the
paper that is backed
by subprime assets and
that are insured by AIG--
once the insurance
disappears, they
are obligated, a number of them,
to sell those pieces of paper.
If you're a pension
fund, you are
obligated to hold only
investment grade assets.
If it turns out
that for any reason
those assets become lower
than investment grade--
and we're going to talk
about this at 4 o'clock today
at that proseminar.
If it falls below
investment grade, by law,
you are obligated to
get rid of those assets.
Now, what do you think
would happen to the market
if everybody all at once decided
to get rid of those assets?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Right.
And then, there'd
be a mass panic.
Right.
STUDENT: I just have--
there's something
simple that I don't understand.
How can the interest rate
go below the inflation rate?
ANDREW LO: Well,
it's not supposed to
for any extended period of time.
But for any short period
of time, it certainly can.
And what it says is that
the real rate is negative
or that the economy
is contracting.
STUDENT: So like right
now, $1 a year from now
is more valuable than
it [? would be ?] today.
Right?
ANDREW LO: Well, if you
take inflation into account,
yes, in real terms,
not in nominal terms.
You can never have a negative
nominal interest rate.
Right?
Unless, you know, somebody
is burning dollar bills.
But let me let me
hold off on that,
because I want to actually--
that brings us back
to the end of last lecture.
What I want to do
today is, I want
to talk about information
specifically contained
in interest rates.
And we're going to
actually take a look
at what the short-term
interest rate is.
I think you'll be,
kind of, surprised
to see what the three-month
T-bill rate is, as of today.
Anybody know what it is?
You've seen it?
2%?
No.
It's lower.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Let me--
we'll see in just a minute.
Let me start today's
lecture by going back
to where we left off last time.
Last time, we talked about the
pricing of pure discount bonds,
bonds that pay only
principal at the end
and no intermediate
coupon payments.
And we saw that the
price today is simply
equal to the face
value or principal
at the end of the maturity
date, and then discounted back
using the interest rate.
And I pointed out at
the end of last lecture
that the interest
rate can differ,
depending on the horizon.
So a one-year
interest rate is not
the same as a five-year
interest rate,
because the market has
different expectations about how
the economy will do and what
the appropriate borrowing
rate or the time rate
of preference might be.
So in fact, for every horizon--
one year, two years,
three years, five years--
we have a different
interest rate.
It doesn't have to be
different, but in general, it
does tend to be different.
How do we find out what
these interest rates are?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The market.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
The market.
The way to do it is not to think
about interest rates at all,
but rather to auction
off pieces of paper that
pay $1,000 in a year,
$1,000 in two years,
$1,000 in three
years, and so on.
And we auction off each
of these pieces of paper
and see what the prices we fetch
are, for those pieces of paper.
Once we have the
price and once we
know the face
value of $1,000, we
can back out the interest rate.
We can solve for the
interest rate, r.
So that's how we get the rates.
And what I want to do
today is to explicate
what those rates really mean.
I want to show you how
to read the entrails
and see that these rates contain
enormous amounts of information
about the future.
Not all of that
information is good.
So sometimes, it's
misleading and incorrect,
but it's always useful
in one form or another.
Now, to do that,
I want to develop
a little bit of new
notation and get
you to think, yet again,
differently about the evolution
of interest rates over time.
I'm going to define
what's called a spot
rate as the rate of
interest between today
and some other point in time.
And I'm going to talk
about future spot rates
as the interest rates
between some future date,
and then another date
even beyond that.
So to be explicit, I wanted
to find new notation called
capital R. Uppercase R is
meant to convey a one-year spot
rate of interest at a
particular point in time, t.
OK?
So capital R1
denotes the spot rate
of interest between
today and next year.
Capital R3 denotes the
spot rate of interest
between years 2 and 3.
And capital Rt denotes
the one year spot rate
between dates t minus 1 and t.
OK?
So these capital R's are
always one-year rates,
unlike the little r's, which
can denote multi-year rates,
depending on the application.
Now, there's a reason I
wanted to find these big R's.
It turns out that if I have
a pure discount bond that
pays off at year t, then I can
use the one-year spot rates
to compute today's price.
Right?
The one-year spot rate,
when you accumulate
that, when you
multiply them together,
will give you the
accumulated interest
over this entire t-year period.
So if I want to
discount face value, F,
and bring it back
to year zero, I
can just assume that
there exists one rate.
Or I can say, you know what?
If there are multiple rates
that differ year by year,
I can use those
individual rates.
So I get that first equation.
Now, we don't observe them.
So this is a pure fiction, in
terms of what I'm writing down.
It's a theory.
So I'm not telling you that we
know what those big R's are.
But I know that they exist,
and whatever they are,
this is what the price of
the bond ought to be today.
Any questions about that?
OK.
Now, what I do observe is the
price and F. Those things,
I get from the marketplace and
the contract for these bonds.
Therefore, it turns out that
as a very simple identity,
this expression, this little r--
which-- I'm adding some
more complicated notation
to indicate when I begin
and when I end in terms
of my horizon--
I can simply define this
little r as being equal
to the geometric average
of these big R's.
It's really just
terminology at this point.
Right?
I'm simply saying
that in reality, we
have one-year interest rates
that may change over time.
And I know that the
price of the bond today
is equal to the future course
of one-year interest rates
as discounts over that period.
When I use those
as discount rates,
I bring back the value F,
and I get today's price.
I can just as well write that
chain of one-year interest
rates as a single number,
raised to the t-th power.
I can always do that.
You can think of this
little r as an average,
a geometric average,
of the big R's.
Right?
So the strict definition
is going to be--
little r is going to be the
t-th root of the product,
and then minus 1.
That's what the little r is.
All right?
You take that product, and
you raise that to the 1
over t-th power or
take the t-th root,
and then subtract 1 from that--
that's what my little r is.
Now, why am I going
through all of this?
It's because I want
to show you that
from a theoretical perspective,
the little r, which
we can observe,
contains information
about the future course
of interest rates.
Within the little r
are all the big R's--
at least today's expectations
of what those big R's are
going to be.
So it turns out that if we
look into the little r's, we
can actually develop
insight about what's
going to be happening next
year, five years from now,
30 years from now.
Now, let me give you an
example, just to make sure
that we understand the mechanism
by which these little r's
and big R's are determined.
Here's a set of
prices of strips.
These are treasury securities,
issued by the US government.
And then, a third party buys
them, takes the coupons,
creates separate
securities, and sells
those separate securities,
each one of which
is one of these coupons.
So from our perspective, they
look like pure discount bonds.
There's no intermediate
coupon payments
for each one of these
strips, and the maturity
is three months, six
months, one year, two years,
up to 30 years.
OK?
And those are the prices.
So a three-month strip
is currently priced--
as of August the 1st, 2001, it
was priced at a little bit less
than the dollar.
So how do we figure out what
the little r is, associated
with those various prices?
Well, let's take an example.
The five-year strip is priced
at, about, $0.80 to the dollar.
OK?
So the price is
0.797, and that's
equal to $1 paid
five years later.
So therefore, it's $1
discounted back five years.
So I'm gonna use my little
r, and the zero comma five
indicates that it's today's
spot rate for borrowing
over a five-year horizon.
And it turns out that
when I solve for that,
I get a number that's 4.64%.
That's the rate of return,
the cost of capital,
the yield of that
five period horizon.
Any questions about this?
Yeah.
STUDENT: How do we do it,
maybe, if it was one that
was less than a year's horizon?
ANDREW LO: So if it's less
than a year's horizon,
then you basically have
to go the other way,
in terms of the power.
Right?
STUDENT: [? 1 over 1/2. ?]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
Exactly.
That's right.
Yeah, that's it.
It's just a shorter time
horizon than a year.
Now, suppose that we
observe a bunch of these
as we do with the strips.
So in other words, you've
got a five-year rate,
you've got a 10-year rate,
you've got a two-year rate,
and so on.
What does that tell
us about the future?
Well, let's write
down the big R's.
Even though we don't see
them, we know that somehow,
implicitly, they're there.
So what are the relationships
between the little
r's and the big R's?
Well, you'll see something
really neat emerge out of this.
We'll start with
a one-year strip.
With a one-year strip,
the little r and the big R
are the same, because
it's only one year.
So there's a one-year big
R, a one-year little r,
and when you work
out the math, they're
actually equal to each other.
But now, when you go with
two years, three years, and t
years, it gets a little
bit more complicated.
Take a look at
what happens if you
take the price of the
one-year, and you divide that
into the price of the two-year.
These two securities-- the
one-year and the two-year--
they have the same F,
the same face value.
They pay $1,000 at maturity.
But one of them goes for
one year, and one of them
goes for two years.
What happens when
you take P 0,1,
and you divide that by P 0,2?
By the way, both of
those prices exist today.
Right?
For example, if you take
a look at the strips,
the price of P 0,1 is 0.967.
The price of P 0,2 is 0.927.
If I take the price of 1
divided by the price of 2,
what do I get?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
I get 1 plus R2.
And so if I subtract
1 from that, I get R2.
So let's just go back.
I don't have a calculator with
me, but I'm sure all of you do.
Somebody do that division
for me, will you?
Can you take 0.967 and
divide that by 0.927?
What do you get?
0.967 divided by 0.927.
What's that?
STUDENT: 1.04.
ANDREW LO: 1.04-- and
then, subtract 1 from that.
4%.
Actually, can you give me a
few more digits of accuracy?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: What's that?
STUDENT: 4.314.
ANDREW LO: 4.314.
So it turns out that
in year 0, where
we have all of these
prices, we actually
have a forecast
for what big R2 is.
Big R2 in this case
is the borrowing cost
between year 1 and year 2.
But we're sitting at year 0.
So implicit in the price of a
two-year bond and a one-year
bond--
implicit in that is a forecast
of what the price is going
to be, what the
yield is going to be,
or what the borrowing
costs is going
to be between years 1 and 2.
In this case, 4.3% or so.
And that's a really
important observation.
If you plot these little r's on
a graph as a function of time,
you actually get a sense of
where the future big R's are
going to lie.
This plot, a plot of the
r's as a function of time,
is known as the term structure
of interest rates or the yield
curve, and it gives you a
sense of where future interest
rates are going to go.
If the curve is upward-sloping,
it says that as you go out
into longer maturities,
your average yield,
the geometric average
of all the big R's--
it's getting bigger
as time grows,
as the time horizon grows.
If it's downward-sloping,
it suggests
that future interest rates,
future big R's, are declining.
I want to show you what the
yield curve looks like today.
Now, it turns out that we don't
have a yield curve of strips
as readily available as a
yield curve that includes
coupon payments.
So I'm going to come
back to the distinction
a little bit later on.
We haven't talked
about coupon bonds yet,
but I just want to show you
what the yield curve is.
So I'm on the Bloomberg website.
This is publicly
available, so I don't have
a particular license for it.
It's the public version.
And if you click on market
data, and then click
on rates and bonds, you're going
to get this page right here.
So these are the different
US treasury securities,
the different horizons.
These are the coupons.
For less than a year, there
are no coupon payments,
so these are pure
discount bonds.
And there's the graph.
That's it.
That graph-- the green line is
showing you the future course
of interest rates.
It's extremely low today.
The scale is on the
left-hand access.
And by the way,
these are in percent.
So where we are today,
for a three-month rate,
is close to zero.
It's actually
three basis points,
three basis points for
a three-month T-bill.
What does that tell you?
What's the relationship
between price and the little r?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, that's right.
But how does that
yield get so low?
Yes?
STUDENT: Because the
price is extremely high.
ANDREW LO: The price
is extremely high.
That's right.
Price is equal to the
three-month pay-out divided
by 1 plus little r.
If little r ends up being
really, really tiny,
it's only because the
price is really high.
Why would the price be high?
STUDENT: Because US
treasuries are the safe thing
to own right now.
ANDREW LO: At least, that's
what many people think, exactly.
There is a really strong
flight to liquidity going on
in markets, as of today.
And how do you know
that it's as of today?
Well, take a look
at the difference
between the green line
and the orange line.
The orange line was
what it was yesterday.
You see, there's a difference.
There's a noticeable difference
on the short end that
means a lot of people are out
there buying treasury bills
now, probably as we speak.
Maybe you ought to go and
buy some treasury bills.
People are scared.
And they're scared
because of all the things
that are going on in the
news, and this is exactly what
the Fed is trying to stave off.
So you're absolutely right.
The Fed is not worried
about the cost of borrowing.
They're worried
about whether or not
there's money out there
to be able to calm
the fears of market
participants.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
two days ago
to today, [INAUDIBLE] probably
the Fed didn't cut the interest
rate once [INAUDIBLE].
They [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: That's right.
They might have to, so
that expectation actually
is built into these prices.
The market recognizes
that, and they're worried.
But think about that.
If the Fed has said that they're
going to be cutting rates--
possibly cutting rates
in the future, and yet,
the rate stays relatively
high going forward,
and rates go down
today, what that's
telling you is that the market
is being driven by a panic
reaction.
Now, rates are going to go up.
So the fact that you see the
market determining a yield
curve that's
upward-sloping-- that's
telling you that people
expect that rates
are going to go up, that
rates have to go up,
for one of two reasons.
And in fact, you can take a look
at the steepness of the yield
curve as telling you what
the market's expectations are
for how quickly rates
are going to go up
and where they're
going to go up.
So you have to look at
the x-axis a little bit
differently.
These are denominated
in years, so this
is three months, six months,
one year, two, three, four,
five, up to 10--
then, 15, 20, and 30.
So these are long-term rates.
And you can see that the yield
curve really goes up sharply
after the first three months.
There's a big
increase in the slope,
and then it becomes a
little bit more gradual.
That's a sign of a short-term
flight to quality or flight
to liquidity.
But the market
expects, over time
as things calm down, that
interest rates will go up,
for one of two reasons.
Either there are inflationary
pressures and that
will drive rates
up, or there are
going to be some economic
consequences of what's
happening today, and
that will ultimately
cause rates to go up.
Yeah.
STUDENT: What's happening
to the interest rates
outside of this case?
Because I'm from Argentina,
and when we have crises,
like [? internal ?]
interest rates go up,
because the probability
of default increases.
And now, I see here, it's
the other way around,
because they are not
considering it will be--
ANDREW LO: That's right.
It depends on the
nature of the crisis.
So in certain countries where
there is a financial crisis,
the typical reaction
of monetary authorities
is to flood the
market with cash,
because that's their reaction
to a liquidity crunch.
They want to reduce the
prospect of having a kind of run
on the banks, so they'll flood
the market with their currency.
When you do that, you
encourage inflation,
and that's why interest rates go
up in those kinds of economies.
The US, for better or for worse,
has shown a certain degree
of monetary restraint over the
years in that while they do
certainly cut interest rates--
and Alan Greenspan was very
active in this respect over
the last 10 or 15 years--
the fact is that
there has been more
measured control of monetary
policy in the United States.
What that means is that
this is a symptom more
of a short-term cash crunch.
People are just putting
money in treasury bills
for the short term
without any expectation
that the Fed is going to
dramatically increase the money
supply.
If they did that,
you would then see
interest rates rise,
because inflation would
be much more of a problem.
OK.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
European Central Bank?
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
STUDENT: --normally raises the
interest rates [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW LO: That's right.
They do raise it, and that's
one of the reasons why
the Fed did not cut it.
It's because they are
concerned with inflation.
And so if they ended up
cutting interest rates,
while that might stave off
certain credit crunches,
that would actually
encourage inflation.
STUDENT: So inflation does
encourage higher interest
rates, but what is the
[? advantage ?] of it?
ANDREW LO: Inflation causes--
so I see the confusion, and
let me make a distinction.
There are two different interest
rates that are going on.
There is the market
rate of interest,
which is what this is.
And then, there is the Fed's
stated federal funds rate,
which is what it
charges its other member
banks for borrowing.
The Fed is able to control
what it charges to other banks.
The Fed cannot
control these rates.
So the interest rates that
you're thinking about, that--
for example, when
the ECB raises rates,
they do so, so as to discourage
lots of borrowing and lending,
and reduce the amount of
money that's in circulation.
And that decreases
business activity,
which then reduces the
pressure on inflation.
OK?
So that's what they
do in response,
but they don't control the
interest rate determined
by the market for
treasury bills.
And in these interest
rates, these 30-year rates,
as opposed to overnight
borrowing rates and Fed funds
rates, these rates
give you a sense
of what the market is
expecting over time.
[? Megan, ?] do you
have a question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] As it
cuts the interest rates,
[INAUDIBLE] had an impact
[INAUDIBLE] the actual banks
that [? spread ?] over time
[INAUDIBLE] to stave off that
credit crunch--
ANDREW LO: Well, that's right.
I think that when you
think about the instruments
that the Fed has for managing
monetary policy, credit,
and liquidity, it's
actually pretty minimal.
I mean, they have one variable.
You know?
Imagine flying a mirror plane
and you get one control.
You pick the control.
You want to be able to control
the wheels, or the ailerons,
or the--?
It's very, very hard
to try to manage
the economy with one variable.
Now, the Fed has other
policy instruments
that are a little bit more
complex, like the discount
window, like moral suasion.
The New York Fed can
go to these banks
and say, what are
you guys doing?
Are you nuts?
But what's going on now is that
because the crisis has reached
such an extraordinary
level, they're not
worrying about interest rates.
They're actually
trying to figure out
how to stave off some
kind of mass panic.
And so getting directly
involved with AIG,
getting in discussions with
Bear Stearns and JP Morgan--
they really have no choice.
And it's a signal of, sort
of, how desperate times are.
One last question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] My
understanding is first
that the Fed is not a
federal organization.
It's made up of a
number of banks,
so that it's not a
government entity,
but the government has
appointed representatives to it.
And at the same time,
where does the Fed
get all their money from?
ANDREW LO: Well, this
is more of a question
that you probably should be
asking your macro instructor.
I'm happy to answer
it, but the macro folks
may disagree with what
I'm about to tell you.
The Fed is a government
organization.
It's separate from the
government in the sense
that it's not a
political organization,
but it does have the full
backing of the government,
and it has powers
granted to it as part
of the various
legal proposals that
were developed to create
the Federal Reserve system.
Where does the Fed
get its money from?
It gets its money
from the treasury.
So the Fed can
actually engage in what
are called open
market operations
and can actually contract
or expand money supply,
based upon what the
treasury will allow it to do
or will work with it to do.
And the Fed controls
the borrowing rate
among all of the member
banks, and actually, all
of the major banks are members.
So it's not like you can
start up your bank tomorrow.
In order to start a bank
and deal with the public,
you need a bank charter,
and the bank charter
is issued by the government.
And once you're part
of that network,
you are part of the
Federal Reserve system.
STUDENT: Aren't they
losing money from, say,
the fallout of
these [? banks? ?]
Aren't they, in essence,
losing also themselves?
ANDREW LO: Well, they're
not trying to make money.
That's not their objective.
And if they're losing
money, ultimately, it's
not them that is losing money.
It is-- who?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
We're losing money.
It's government-sponsored.
So that's one of the
reasons why, I think,
the Fed has been so
concerned about bailing out
Lehman Brothers.
And even the bailout of
Bear Stearns, which did not
necessarily cost them anything--
the fact that they were willing
to provide this backstop
guarantee in order to
make the deal happen--
that implicit
insurance is a cost
that we ultimately
end up paying.
They got a huge amount
of heat for that,
and that's one of the reasons
why they decided to back off
from the Lehman Brothers deal.
It's because they would have
gotten huge, huge backlash
from that kind of an event.
Now, AIG-- the fact
that they went and did
something there
tells you something
about how important
AIG is, or what
repercussions might have come
about if they had let AIG fail.
So that says more,
not about the Fed,
but more about the
situation with AIG
and the specific
financial transactions
that they were engaged in.
OK.
Let me continue on.
And sorry, I want to hold off
questions for a little bit
longer, but I do want to cover
some additional material.
So this is the
expression that we just
described for getting a sense
of future interest rates.
And we saw, given
today's yield curve,
that there is some sense
that interest rates are
going to rise.
But it turns out that
the yield curve contains
all sorts of information, not
just about one-year rates,
but in fact, about
multi-year rates.
This is a clear example.
This is one example.
And it turns out that
there's another example that
makes this a little
bit clearer, which is
future rates and forward rates.
These are all very
confusing terminology,
unless you sit down and
read through it carefully,
so I would encourage you all
to do that after this lecture.
There's a lot of
notation in this lecture,
but not a lot of
conceptual challenges.
Because all the
conceptual challenges,
we derived when we talked
about net present value rules.
So most of this is just lots
of notation and terminology.
So let me describe
the terminology here.
At date zero, if we focus
on the price of a bond,
that matures at time t minus 1.
And at date zero, if we focus
on the price of a bond that
matures at day t, and we
take the ratio of those two,
then it turns out, we're
getting an implicit forecast
of the future one-year spot
rate between t minus 1 and t.
Right?
That's just what we did with r2.
So this is true in
general, and there's
a name for this forecast.
It's called,
today's forward rate
between dates t minus 1 and t.
It is a forecast of
the future spot rate
between dates t minus 1 and t.
OK?
We don't know what that
spot rate is going to be,
in general.
We don't know what future
interest rates are going to be.
It's uncertain.
But today, implicit
in today's prices
is a forecast of
that unknown future,
and we're going to call that
forecast the forward rate.
That is really meant to convey
that it is a rate that we
observe today, and it is meant
to capture the market's best
guess about what the
future spot rate will be.
OK?
So this is, I know, a
little bit confusing.
And just to give you a
summary of all the notation
and terminology
we've defined today--
we have a spot rate.
A spot rate is the rate
that you have to pay
or that you will earn on the
spot, for a period of time.
So you've got the
two-year spot rate today.
You've also got future
spot rates, which you
don't know and don't observe.
You also have a forward rate,
which you do observe today.
And the forward rate
is a rate that applies
over some period in the future.
And it's today's best guess of
what that future rate will be.
Now, we can see the
implicit forecasts
that are in the yield curve.
The one-year spot
rate today also
happens to be equal to
the one-year forward rate.
However, if you take a look
at the two-year spot rate
and compare that with
the one-year spot rate,
you can compute the
one-year forward rate
for borrowing between
years 1 and 2.
And similarly, if you compare
the four-year spot rate
with the three-year
spot rate, you
will be able to figure out
what the forward rate is
for borrowing one
year between 3 and 4.
OK?
Now, you might think
this is complicated.
Believe me.
It gets even more
complicated when you think
about multi-year forward rates.
So suppose I asked you, what
is the two-year borrowing
rate, three years from now?
Then, what you would do is
to take a five-year bond
and compare that to
a three-year bond,
and that would give you the
two-year forward rate today,
starting in year 3.
OK?
Lots of different rates.
This is, again, why I've
told you, every time you
have a problem like
this, draw a timeline.
Otherwise, you're going to
get hopelessly confused.
Now, in general, you
can define forward
interest rates between any two
points in time, between time t1
and t2.
And so the typical
forward transaction
is one where today, we
agree to do a deal that
starts at some point
t1 in the future
and concludes at some
point t2 in the future.
And that's known as a
forward transaction.
It's a transaction that
we agree upon today,
to engage in sometime
in the future.
Now, I want to work
through an example,
because this is a bit confusing.
So let me show you
how this might work,
and why the whole idea of
forward rates and future spot
rates is so important.
A practical example is that you
are the chief financial officer
of a multinational
company based in the US,
and you're going to
get $10 million a year
from now, from
operations overseas.
And it's going to come back
in the form of dollars,
but it's not going
to come back today.
It's going to come back
exactly one year from today.
Now, you've got to pay
dividends two years from today.
So you're going to use
that money that's going
to come in a year from now.
And then, at the end of year
2, you're going to pay it out.
And so you don't want to
take that money next year
and fool around with it.
You don't know what interest
rates are going to be.
But what you'd like
to be able to do
is, today, lock in a rate of
return between years 1 and 2.
Because you know that you're
going to need to get that money
invested in year
1, and you'd like
to be able to pay
it out in year 2.
And you want to
do that all today.
So how do you do that?
Well, you go to the
financial markets,
and you look at the yield curve.
And you see what the
one-year rate is,
and what the two-year rate is.
And what you get from
looking at the newspaper is,
the one-year rate is 5%,
and the two-year rate is 7%.
Question-- is 7% a spot
rate, forward rate,
or future spot rate?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: It's a
spot rate of what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
It is today's spot rate between
now and two years from now.
It's a two-year spot rate.
Right.
What you care about,
though, for the example
I just gave you, is what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
You care about the one-year
spot rate in one year,
the future one-year
spot rate, which--
you don't know what
it's going to be.
That's uncertain.
But you do have the--
what rate do you have today?
The forward rate, right.
You have a forward rate.
Because you've got the
two-year spot rate,
and you've got the
one-year spot rate.
So when you compare the two,
implicitly in those two rates
is the forecast of the
future one-year spot rate
or today's forward rate
between years 1 and 2.
All right.
Now, let's get to brass tacks.
How do you go about locking
in the rates between years 1
and 2?
Well, here's a really cool
transaction that you can do.
Today, borrow $9.524
million for a year.
How do you know you can do that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
You've got the one-year
interest rate at 5%.
So if that's really
a market rate,
that means that you should be
able to borrow at that rate.
OK?
So when you're borrowing
money, what are you doing?
You're-- are you buying a bond?
You're selling a bond.
You're issuing a bond.
Right.
OK.
So you borrowed $9.52
million dollars today.
Now, in a minute,
I'll explain to you
why that number is so weird.
Then, after you get
the money today,
I'm going to ask you to put
it into the two-year bond.
So you got $9.52
million in cash,
and you put it into
a two-year bond.
So let's take a
look at what you've
done with that transaction.
The outcome looks like this.
In year zero, you've
borrowed 9.52,
and then you've
taken the proceeds
and you've bought
a bond at 9.52.
So in fact, your net
expenditures is nothing.
You borrowed money,
you took that money,
and you bought something else.
You've loaned it out.
You borrowed money for one
year, and you've loaned it out
for two years.
That's what you've done.
So today, you
actually have zero,
in terms of your
assets and liabilities.
Now, let's see what
happens next year.
In one year's time, that 9.52
to magically turns into 10,
but it's a negative 10,
meaning you borrowed 9.52.
You've got to pay back
9.52 with interest.
How much interest?
5%.
That's the one-year rate.
So now, you actually have
to pay back $10 million.
Well, it just so happens,
you have $10 million.
How?
From the money that's coming
in from your subsidiary,
that repatriation
amount of money.
So you take that $10
million, you pay it back,
and you're done with that
part of your portfolio.
What do you have left?
What you have left
is a bond that
will pay you money in the year
after that, between years 1
and 2.
And there you go.
You get paid $10.9 million.
You've done all of
this transaction today.
You've locked in
the rates today.
OK?
Yeah?
STUDENT: You locked in the
one-year spot rate [INAUDIBLE]??
ANDREW LO: That's right.
Well, you're locking
in the forward rate,
which is the forecast--
right.
It's what the market expects
the future one-year spot
rate will be.
Now, that's a good
point that you bring up,
which is, let's
say that in year 1,
it turns out that at
that point in time,
the one-year spot rate is 7%.
Are you happy or are you sad?
Some people say said,
some people say happy.
If the one-year spot rate
one year from now is 7%,
and you've done
this deal already--
STUDENT: You're happy.
ANDREW LO: You're happy.
That's right.
Because, what are you
getting on your portfolio?
9%.
Now, wait a minute.
How do you get 9%?
I thought that I told you
the two-year rate was 7%.
I'm purposely confusing
you, so I'm hoping it works.
And then, I'm going to
try to un-confuse you,
and I hope that works, too.
5% is the one-year spot rate.
7% is the two-year spot rate.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Right.
That's right.
The rate between years
1 and 2 is around 9%.
And the reason it's
got to be that way
is, the 7% that I told you--
that's a two-year rate.
Right?
That's the average of two years.
But you know what the
rate is the first year.
The first year rate is 5%.
So if something averages
to 7% over 2 years,
but the first year
is 5, the second year
has got to be greater than 7.
Otherwise, the
average can't be 7.
In fact, the second year rate--
the one year rate between
years 1 and 2 is around 9%.
And so that's why if when you
arrive at the end of year 1,
ready to borrow
for one more year,
and you've already
locked in a 9% rate,
you are pretty happy that
the rate at that time is 7.
However, if I told you that
the rate at that time was 15,
you'll be kicking yourself,
because you locked
in a 9% rate, and yet it's 15%.
So there's room for regret
as well as celebration,
depending on what the
market is going to do.
But the point is
that in year zero,
I don't know what
it's going to be.
And I'm not a
hedge fund manager.
I'm not a trader.
I don't care--
I don't want to make a bet
on future interest rates.
I just want to get
this problem solved.
And right now,
today, I can actually
solve my problem
of figuring out how
to invest my money
between years 1 and 2
by doing this very simple
transaction in open markets
with market-determined
interest rates.
And I know, as long as the
interest rates are not nuts,
then I'm getting
a reasonable deal.
Yeah?
STUDENT: This is one of the main
[? things that you can do. ?]
Could you please [INAUDIBLE] is
it even similar in the same--
at the end of year 1,
I get my 10 million,
put it in [INAUDIBLE],, because
it's pretty much [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
But the problem
is that you don't
know what that one-year
T-bill rate will be,
whereas right now,
you know that it's 9%.
Right now, you know
it's 9%, and it
seems like a pretty good
deal to go ahead and do it.
If, however, you think that
interest rates are going
to go up much more
than the market thinks,
then you may want to wait.
But now, you're becoming an
interest rate speculator.
You're taking a risk.
And as a CFO, that's
generally not your job and not
your level of competency.
Right?
You're not there trying to
forecast interest rates.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: That's right.
The 9.524 is the present
value of $10 million today,
at the rate of 5% interest.
So the way that I did this--
and you know, this is
a good illustration
of what I've been
telling you about finance
not being a spectator sport.
I suspect that all
of you understand
the lectures that I've given
so far about present value,
about time value of money,
and the fact that you've got
to use the right exchange rate.
It all is pretty
straightforward.
But putting it into practice is
not so easy, at least for me.
I don't find this
example so transparent.
You have to actually spend
some time thinking about it,
thinking about where the
money is coming from,
where the money is
going, how much money
you have at any point in time.
But when you work it
out, it all makes sense.
And so I would
encourage all of you
to spend some time
working this out.
OK, question?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yes,
there are ways you
can engage in a forward
contract, of course.
So you don't have to do this.
But the fact is doing
this is so simple.
Why not?
And if it's simple, most
likely, it'll be cheap.
If it's complex, that's when
you're going to pay for it.
Right?
So I'm happy to structure a
derivative product for you.
Let's call it a
structured product
that we trade over
the counter, where
I offer you a forward
contract, one-year borrowing,
with certain terms and
privileges, and so on.
And by the time
we're done, I'm going
to charge you a transaction
fee of-- oh, I don't know,
maybe 5%.
Versus, you buy a two-year
bond and a one-year bill,
and you're done.
Right?
So that's the difference.
It's really the ease with which
you can implement the strategy.
All of you right now, today--
all of you can do this.
You can do this.
You can actually trade
in these markets.
Set up a brokerage account,
trade these treasury
instruments, and
do this yourself.
In fact, you can do this online.
So it's very, very simple.
And-- yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
$10 million?
ANDREW LO: Oh, yeah.
[STUDENTS LAUGHING]
Well, that's the hard part.
Yeah.
There's an old Steve
Martin joke that says,
I'm going to show you how
to make a million dollars
and pay no taxes.
First, get a million dollars.
So yes, that's the hard part.
OK.
So now, this transaction
today locks you
into a 9% rate
between years 1 and 2.
And so going back
to the question
that [? Anan ?]
raised, should you
do this or should you just wait?
Well, it depends.
Do you feel lucky?
Do you think you can
do better than 9%?
I mean, today, 9%
looks wonderful,
but that's not with the rate
you're going to get today.
In fact, if we go back
to the Bloomberg site,
you can see what kind
of rate you would lock
in today between years 1 and 2.
And I promise you,
it's nowhere near 9%.
And so again, you
might actually say--
in today's low interest
rate environment,
you might say, look,
I think that inflation
is going to heat up a great
deal over the next year,
and therefore what's implicit in
today's forecast of future spot
rates is lower than I
think it ought to be.
So I'm going to hold off.
That's a bet.
And so you're going
to take some risks.
That's all.
And for those people who are
good at taking risks like that,
they end up doing well.
For those who don't,
they end up losing out
on good opportunities.
There's another example that
I'd like you to look at and work
through on your own.
It's very similar
to the first one,
but it just gives you practice
in thinking about timelines,
moving money back
and forth, and trying
to understand how to structure
the payoffs in order to satisfy
certain consumption patterns.
So if you look at this
example and work it through,
that will give you more
practice on how to deal
with these transactions.
Now, if there are no more
questions about pure discount
bonds, I want to turn to the
more general case of coupon
bonds.
These are bonds that
pay off coupons.
And really, the theory
behind coupon bonds
is virtually identical to that
of discount bonds, in the sense
that you can always
look at a coupon bond
as a package of discount bonds.
Right?
That's, sort of, the
opposite of a strip.
A strip takes a coupon
bond and breaks it up
into what look like
little discount bonds.
Well, if you think about
what a coupon bond is,
it's really just a
collection of discount bonds
at different maturities.
That's the way to
think about it.
Here's a simple example.
A three-year bond
with a 5% coupon
is going to look like this.
It's going to pay 50,
50, and then 1,050.
Now, as I mentioned, there
are some coupon bonds
that pay semiannually.
So when they say that
there's a coupon of 3%,
it's 3% every six months.
So you have to take
that into account
when you're computing
the present values
of these objects.
How do we do it?
Exactly the same way as we
do for pure discount bonds.
Take the coupons, each of
them, and discount them back
to the present, using either
the big R's or the little r's.
Either way, you ought
to get the same answer,
because the little r's are
simply the geometric averages
of the big R's.
OK?
However, instead of
using the little r's
for the different
payments, coupon bonds
are often quoted with a
single number that is a yield.
So the theoretically correct
way to write the price
is given up there.
P0 is equal to C,
all the coupons,
divided by the
appropriate big R's.
Or we could replace every
one of those big R's
with the appropriate little r.
By appropriate little r, I mean,
little r 0,1, little r 0,2,
too little r 0,3--
each of those.
But we can also
calculate an average
of all of those little r's
and just use one variable.
And to simplify notation, I'm
going to give it a completely
different symbol, Y, and say, ,
what is that single number, Y,
that will give me the
price of the bond?
And that Y is known as the
particular bond's yield.
It is the single
interest rate which,
if interest rates were
constant throughout time,
would make the present value of
all the coupons and principal
equal to the current price.
So if you think
about a mortgage,
and you ask the question,
if the mortgage rate
is 5%, what is the
value of the loan,
that's exactly this
expression right here.
Now, obviously, when you get a
fixed rate mortgage of 5.89%,
you know that the interest
rate is not really
going to be 5.98% forever.
The interest rate
changes every year.
But that 5.98% is an average
of the 30-year period where
you're going to be borrowing
that mortgage money.
So you can think of this coupon
bond in exactly the same way.
We quote this
number Y as a yield.
Sometimes, we talk about
yield instead of prices.
But the way that we
figure out the yield
is, we take this
30-year bond that
pays 5% a year,
we auction it off,
and we figure out
what the price is.
Given the price, we
can find the yield.
Finding the yield is not
so easy in this case,
because in this case, unlike
just taking a simple geometric
average, which is what we did
to calculate the little r's from
the big R's--
in this case, in
order to find the Y,
we actually have to
solve an equation that
can be highly non-linear.
In fact, it's a polynomial.
It's a t-th order polynomial.
And for those of you high
school math team jocks,
you'll remember that when
you've got a t-th order
polynomial, first of all,
you have a lot of solutions.
How many solutions do
you typically have?
t.
And of those solutions,
how many of them
are guaranteed to
be real numbers?
Right.
There's no guarantee that
any of them are real.
Now, you might ask, what
do you mean by real?
Well, if you're asking me,
you don't need to know.
[LAUGHTER] Don't-- don't.
It means numbers that
we encounter in reality.
Let's put it that way.
It turns out that there
are numbers that actually
don't exist in reality.
They're called complex numbers.
And they are quite complex,
so I won't talk about them.
But these kinds of equations--
it turns out that
they're not guaranteed
to even have real solutions.
Now, it turns out
that for bonds,
where the coupon
payments are all positive
and the principle
is all positive,
it turns out in that
very restrictive--
and the price is positive.
It turns out in those cases, you
actually do get a real number--
at least, one real number.
The problem is
that in some cases,
you get multiple real numbers.
And then, it's very, very
hard to figure out which yield
is the correct one to use.
The only reason I'm
telling you about this
is because it turns out
as a matter of convention,
very often, people will quote
these little Y yields when
they talk about coupon bonds.
But the way to
think about that is
to think about the
price, which is
the present value of the coupon
payments as a present discount
value of the interest that
really applies between today
and date t.
In fact, in order to do this
present value calculation,
you need not just
one interest rate.
How many interest
rates do you need?
t, right?
You're at year zero,
and you've got payments
for every single
year between 1 and t.
So you need interest rates
that apply between 0 and 1, 0
and 2, 0 and 3, and so on.
You need t interest
rates or exchange rates.
Right?
Or exchanges between
different dates.
But now, the yield is
important because it
allows us to quote the
pseudo rate of return
of this bond in a single number.
And very often, people will
plot the Y's as a function
of the horizon of these bonds.
So when I showed you
that yield curve--
let me get that back.
Whoops.
I just had it.
Let's take a look at this again.
These treasury bonds from
years 2 to years 30--
those have coupon payments,
and those are the coupon rates.
And they have prices,
and they have yields.
So what's plotted here
is not the little r.
It's the Y for the coupon bonds.
And so the reason that
they're not the same
is because the yields,
the little Y's, depend
on the coupon payments.
And really strictly
speaking, we don't
care about coupon payments when
we look at time to maturity.
We just want to know,
what is the interest
rate between 0 and 1, 0 and 2,
0 and 3, 0 and 5, and so on.
But this is a
reasonable proxy as long
as the coupons
don't look too crazy
and are not too different
from each other.
And you can see that the
coupons are all, sort of,
in the same neighborhood.
Some of them are
2.3% versus 4.5%,
but they're not so different.
So this gives us an indication
of what the strip's yield
curve would look like.
Here's an example of
the historical yield
curve for US
Treasury securities,
and let me just show you a plot.
They move around a lot.
So these yield curves
tell us something
about the average
interest rate across
various different maturities.
So if you look at
the yellow line,
that's a one-year
yield over time.
So this is not the
yield curve anymore.
This is a plot of
the time series
of one-year yields over time.
And you can see that starting
when the sample began in 1982,
the one-year yield for
US Treasury bills is 12%.
12% back in 1982--
and there is a point at which
one of the longer maturity
instruments reaches
a peak of 16% or 17%.
Remember, I told you, I
was looking to get a house
and get a mortgage at 18%.
That was a 30-year fixed
rate back in the 1980s.
So borrowing rates
are very, very low
by these historical standards.
If borrowing rates
are very low, what
does that tell you about credit
and about the amount of cash
sloshing around in the economy?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly--
lots and lots
and lots of money available.
So for those of you
who are thinking
about entrepreneurial
ventures-- if you're
thinking about
raising capital, you
might be depressed by what's
going on in markets today.
But look at the interest
rate and ask yourself,
gee, would I rather start a
company today or back in 1982?
There's a heck of a
lot more money sloshing
around the system today.
In fact, a few years
ago, I talked to a couple
of MIT undergraduates.
One of them came up and
asked me whether I'd
be willing to advise them on
some internet company they
wanted to start.
And you know, I said, well,
you know, where are you
going to get your financing?
And they said, oh,
don't worry about that.
We've already got it all set.
You know, we've got 10
of us, and each of us
is able to borrow $1,000
each on credit cards,
and we each have 10 credit
cards, so that's $100,000.
And I'm saying, $100,000
on credit cards?
I mean, you guys are going
to be paying 18% a year
or something on that.
And they said,
yeah, you know what?
That's the cheapest venture
financing you'll ever find.
And they're right, because
those are non-recourse loans.
They don't take a
piece of your company.
And 18% for a venture is
actually pretty attractive.
Well, look at what the
borrowing rate is now.
Now, you can't borrow at
this rate for ventures,
but it indicates that there's
a lot of credit out there,
and there's still a lot
of credit out there.
In fact, the
treasury and the Fed
would argue there's too
much credit out there.
And that's why we're in the
problems that we are today.
Because too many people--
people that should not have
been leveraging and borrowing
have done so.
And now, we're feeling the
pains of a contraction.
So this is the history
of yield curves.
And at a given point in time, we
can take a look at yield curves
and see how that curve
changes day to day.
I showed you today's yield
curve, which is upward sloping.
But you know, there was
a period back in 2000
where this yield curve was
actually upward-sloping,
and then downward-sloping.
Why would the yield curve
be downward-sloping?
What that tells
you is that there's
an expectation of the
market participants
that interest rates in the
long run have got to come down,
and that there's going to
be some kind of Fed policy
shift possible within three
years, five years, 10 years,
that would make that
more likely than not.
So by looking at these yield
curves over different dates,
you can get a sense of how
the market's expectations are
of the future, which I think
is a tremendous ability
to actually look into the
future-- at least look
into the future as predicted
by all the market participants.
This is just that yield
curve that I told you about.
This is not in your
notes, but I was
able to copy that from
Bloomberg this morning.
You have that in
the public website.
And now, the next topic I want
to take on-- very briefly,
because there's a lot to be
said about models of the yield
curve, and I won't take
up class time to do that.
This is something
that is a topic that's
more significantly
focused on in investments
and in fixed-income securities.
But one of the things that
we'd like to be able to do
is to try to model that term
structure interest rates.
Is there any logic
that we can come up
with that explains
why the yield curve is
upward-sloping or
backward-bending or inverted?
And it turns out that there
are a number of theories
that have come to be proposed.
I'm not going to cover
any of these in any depth,
but I want to at least mention
the names so that you'll
know that there are theories
out there that will tell you
whether or not the yield curve
should be so steeply sloped
or not.
There's something called
the Expectations Hypothesis.
There is something
called the Liquidity
Preference Hypothesis.
There is a Preferred Habitat
Model, Market Segmentation
Model.
And then, there are a whole
slew of extraordinarily
sophisticated and complex
mathematical models,
one of which--
and probably the
best known of which--
was developed by our very
own John Cox and Steve Ross.
The Cox-Ingersoll-Ross
model of the term structure
of interest rates is probably
the single best known yield
curve model.
It's a very complicated
model, but it
has some pretty
significant implications
for whether the
yield curve ought
to be upward-sloping
or downward-sloping,
or how it changes over time.
I'll give you one example
of what these theories are,
and I won't spend
much time on it,
but I want to at least leave
you with some intuition
for how you would go
about modeling it.
So one model says that today's
forward rates are in fact
the best guess of what future
spot rates are likely to be,
and that's known as the
Expectations Hypothesis.
This hypothesis states that
today's forward rate, which
is what we do observe, is equal
to the mathematical expectation
today, of the future
one-year spot rate.
Now, you might say,
well, that's not
that's not much of a theory.
I mean, what else could it be?
Well, it turns out that there
is another theory called
the Preferred Liquidity
Preference Theory that
says that the longer
the term of borrowing,
the more you're going to have
to pay a premium for people
to lend to you, because
people would prefer liquidity.
So the longer you
demand the borrowing
for a greater period of time,
the more you have to pay--
much more so than just linearly.
So in particular, the
Expectations Hypothesis
suggests that the
yield curve is flat.
Right?
There's no impact on borrowing
for two years, three years,
five years, 10 years.
The future rate
is just equal to--
today's forward rate is the
expectation of the future.
OK?
It's a fair bet.
Liquidity Preference
says that the yield curve
should be upward-sloping,
because it's
going to be more costly
for you to borrow
over a three-year period than
a one-year period, simply
because it's going
to entail somebody
giving up their money for
a longer period of time.
They're going to be less liquid.
You're going to have to bribe
them to be willing to give up
that liquidity.
That's the Liquidity
Preference Theory.
The Preferred
Habitat Theory says,
you know, there are preferred
maturities that people have.
And for those
maturities, you're going
to have different rates than for
those that people don't prefer.
So if you want a
30-year maturity--
and that's not preferred
because it's too far off--
then you're gonna
have to pay a premium.
On the Other Hand,
10 years is a period
that a number of
pension funds prefer,
so you may not have to pay
as much for those preferred
habitats.
And to give you a sense of
where academics is today,
none of these models work.
None of them can fully
explain movements
in the yield curve,
which, by the way,
is a wonderful opportunity
for all of you.
Because if you have a
model that does work,
then you can do
extraordinarily well.
You can turn very, very
small forecast power
into enormous amounts
of wealth very,
very quickly on Wall Street.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Does he--
ANDREW LO: You can't patent it.
Right.
So does he get anything out
of that besides notoriety?
Well, that's a good question.
The question has to do with,
I guess, the difference
between academic endeavors
and business endeavors.
As an academic, what
you're trying to do
is to make a name for
yourself and to put out
research ideas that
will have an impact
with your colleagues and the
particular area that you're in.
So if you're asking,
did Professor Cox
get rich off of this?
The answer is, no, probably not.
Neither did
Black-Scholes, actually,
when they published their
Black-Scholes option pricing
formula.
That was the same year that
the Chicago Board Options
Exchange started trading,
and everybody just
used the option pricing formula
almost from the very start.
Did they make money off of that?
No, they didn't.
And you're right.
You can't patent it.
So very often, in
financial firms,
when they have good ideas--
so for example, I
do believe there
are term structure models out
there that work reasonably
well.
They're not published.
They're kept as the Coca-Colas
of financial markets.
They're trade secrets.
And so if you go there
to work and ultimately
work with the right people, you
will learn such trade secrets,
which, by the way, is one of
the reasons why when Barclays
acquires Lehman and wants
to keep all of these
really, really terrific
people together,
they're going to have to
offer premia to do that.
And so that's part of the
cost of financial distress
when you disturb the status quo.
That's a few models of the term
structure of interest rates.
And I want to talk about one
last topic on coupon bonds
before concluding this lecture.
Next lecture on Monday,
we're going to take up
measures of interest rate risk.
We're going to look explicitly
at what happens when
interest rates bounce around.
Before we get to that, though,
I want to talk about another way
to value coupon bonds,
and it's exactly the idea
that I said before, of using
pure discount bonds to do so.
If I have a pure
discount bond, I
can use that to price
coupon bonds by building up
a package of discount bonds.
The example of the
strips is given here.
You've got a three-year
5% bond, and it turns out
that you can show that that
three-year 5% bond is going
to be identical to 50 one-year
strips, 50 two-year strips,
and 1050 three-year
strips, each strip
paying $1 in years 1, 2, and 3.
Any question about that claim?
Anybody want to argue with
me that that's not true?
It's pretty obvious, right?
Well, this actually has a
very dramatic implication,
and let me tell you what
that implication is.
The implication is that the
price of a three-year 5% bond
better be equal to the cost
of 50 one-year strips, 50
two-year strips, and
1050 three-year strips.
The price of this
three-year bond
better be equal to what it costs
to put that portfolio of strips
together today.
Why?
Why should it be equal?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: What is arbitrage?
We haven't defined that.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] basically,
if the prices are different,
[INAUDIBLE] buy the
one or sell the other,
so they come
together [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
There is a way to make
money if the price
of that three-year bond is
anything other than the cost
of that package of strips.
So let's do an example.
Suppose that the price
of a three-year bond
is greater than the
cost of the strips.
Tell me what to do.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Buy those strips,
package them into a bond,
and then sell it.
Sell the bond to the market.
Just keep doing that
over and over again.
ANDREW LO: OK.
So let's talk about this slowly.
I first buy those strips.
I buy the portfolio strips.
And then, I take
this bond that's
trading in the open
marketplace, and I sell it.
How do I sell
something I don't own?
Short-sell it, yes.
Short-selling, which you can
read about and Brealey, Myers,
and Allen, is when, if you
don't own the security,
you can borrow it from a
broker, and then sell it,
and you'll collect the
money from selling it.
Now, the broker,
obviously, is going
to want you to keep that
money in that brokerage firm
so that you don't
run away with it.
Because you've borrowed
the security at some point,
you've got to pay it back.
You've got to return
that security.
Right?
So the transaction is,
you buy these strips,
you short-sell the bond,
and what have you done?
Have you made money or
lost money on day one?
You've made money.
Why?
Because buying costs less
than the amount of money
you get from selling.
And how do you know that?
Because I just assumed that
it's more expensive for you
to get the three-year bond
than the package of strips.
So you've made
money today, but you
have no further obligations,
because what you end up
getting from the strips--
you've bought the strips,
so you're going to get their
coupons or their face value.
You're going to use those to
pay the coupons of the bonds
that you sold.
And therefore, you have
no further obligations,
but you have a pile of
money in front of you.
That's pretty cool.
And if you do that a lot,
that pile of money grows.
So obviously, we know
it's not easy to do that.
And if it's not easy
to do that, that
means that our assumption
that the bond was greater
than the cost of the
strips can't be true.
If you reverse the logic,
you get the same kind
of argument in reverse.
Therefore, the only
thing that could be
is that the prices are
equal to each other.
Next time, what
we're going to do
is show that a little
bit of linear algebra
is going to allow you
to make tons of money
by comparing all sorts
of bonds and looking
at these kinds of relationships.
OK.
I'll see you at 4:00,
if you're interested.